i'm going to start by asking uh a big
part of
uh dnd and especially critical role was
the improvisational aspect when it came
to adapting it for the tv show uh how
was that like in terms of uh the
dialogue and the script and just playing
off each other
uh i a lot of it was going back and and
revisiting a lot of the original
campaign and ensuring that the dialogue
still carried
a lot of the dialogue from the original
stream or the essence of it you know we
we know these characters so well that
it's it's just kind of carrying that
over into a scripted format along with
the silly interactions and the giving
each other [ __ ] and uh you know playing
little small pranks here and there you
know it's still very much keeping that
heart
um and thankfully we've had a lot of
wonderful creatives helping
flesh out these scripts in a
collaborative way to where we've had
that input where we could tweak we could
make sure that it still keeps the heart
and the feel of what we enjoyed playing
through originally to this animated
medium
how was it uh the collaboration in terms
of picking and choosing what to adapt
for the show basically like what what
story arcs and what to to bring over to
the show
yeah it's definitely i mean there's so
much to
pull from from matt's world
um but i mean the briarwood ark was such
an obvious candidate because the
briarwoods are just
so delicious in everything that they do
and it was one of our favorite arcs from
the first campaign so
we knew pretty early on that we wanted
to explore that
yeah uh my shank ashley how was it for
you guys
to to to bring the characters over in
terms of your performance now that he's
in a more controlled environment than
than he was doing the the streams
it's
it's been really um
i feel like because we have played so
many hours and
so many games and and improv
i don't know how many hours it is all
together now but um
it
it feels more precise
you know being able to sort of truncate
the whole story and have these sort of
bite-sized episodes and sort of taking
some of our favorite moments and
it
of course there's so much more that we
want to put in there but
i feel like we were still able to tell
the story that we wanted to tell in just
the right amount of time
and um
yeah i feel like it's a pretty it it
didn't feel super different to me
sitting at the table or standing behind
the mic with everybody you know we know
these characters so well after all this
time and
it was just fun
it was super fun to be behind a mic and
just knowing that we're putting our
characters onto
into an animated series now
yeah i think we were able to kind of
blast past the
getting to know you phase that a lot of
actors go through with their characters
and i mean yeah i mean that's what it is
yeah you see it all the time and you
hear people talk about it in film and tv
of like oh man i feel like by it
by how many times have you heard by
episode six they really started getting
their stride uh and it is because you go
through this period of trying to really
figure out who these people were but
since we'd already been playing these
characters for hundreds of hours for
several years we were really able to
just jump in and know exactly who they
were and what we wanted to portray with
them
you mentioned having to sort of
uh
take pieces of the larger
unit from the from the stream but was
there anything you wanted to add that
wasn't in the streams uh whether it's
from characterization just story moments
anything at all
there's always a number of small moments
that aren't you know pertinent to the
main story that you would love to have
seen small interactions things that uh
they're just with the cost of animation
and the time that you have don't quite
fit
so
on one hand you're also like well those
moments still exist in the original
stream so you can still enjoy it and how
it first originally came out or we tried
to find ways to still bring them in
by rearranging the timeline a bit and
still included in the story maybe at a
different time or in a slightly
different way but it's still the same
comedic beat or it's still the same
important character interaction that we
loved from the original campaign so the
fun part about an adaptation is you get
to kind of
you get to mess around a little bit with
the original you know format you get to
cut the fat in some places and in others
improve it where an improvised narrative
doesn't you know always hit everything
100 of the time sometimes you you wander
a bit sometimes some silly moments go on
too long here you get to release you
know kind of take the best of the best
and streamline it and make it make it
the best it can be for animation and
while it's been a challenge a really fun
challenge i think it really kind of
makes this a really strong outing for
the story
we also see some moments especially the
first two episodes that are
completely original uh for a trio how
was it to to sort of uh come up with
this story and also to see where the
characters were at before we we saw them
in the in the stream before the the
proper adaptation begins
yeah we played in our living rooms of
three years before we turned a camera on
the stream so there was actually a lot
to pull from from these home game
sessions
and
being able to show something
that our fans of our uh tabletop rpg
show we're unfamiliar with but it's also
it's new for them and it's brand new for
the new audience who have maybe never
heard anything about critical role
before
so it's kind of starting everybody on
this even playing field which was
something that we were really excited
and looking forward to doing
yeah i think it allowed us the the the
opportunity like we're just said to
bring stuff from the home game in
and to really show those early stages
the dynamics
of this this group of misfits who
they work together but they got their
tensions they have their their
miscommunications
and kind of
really get to enjoy the journey that we
got to enjoy as players and as a gm
uh to where it eventually goes in the
onstream game and so uh yeah it's been
it was really fun to kind of create that
new story at the beginning and i i'm
looking forward to people to get to
experience it for the first time
uh matt uh now stepping from
being behind the screen to sort of being
on equal foot with with the actors how
was that for you
uh
knowing
everything as the actors doing sort of
being uh
less in control in a way and did you
want to sort of add more of the
knowledge that you had from before how
was that like for you
uh it i mean it was it was nice to not
be the only person running the story
outside of the players you know having a
of other incredibly talented creative
people helping me make this the best it
can be has been awesome but we've all
been very involved in pretty much every
step of the production you know uh every
single
uh art approval meeting every single you
know story crafting meeting all scripts
went through note passes with the full
cast like we were all all of us very
involved in every part of the creative
as it went through so this wasn't like
just handing the reins to folks and
hoping it turned out okay
you know we wanted to make sure this was
as close as we could get it to
our
hopeful final vision and and we did it
and it's it we're very thankful that we
were given the trust by the people at
amazon prime to to helmet the way we did
and to work with all these wonderful
creative uh folks but uh they didn't
feel that different because we were we
were still involved the whole way
uh for the trio is there any particular
moment that you were
really really sort of fighting like
hoping will make it to the show and also
a moment that you may have wanted to
change from the original stream that you
thought that we have a do-over can we do
something different now that is in
animation form man i can't think of many
do-overs kind of the beauty about
tabletop rpgs in that improv format is
it is what it is and you gotta roll with
the punches and there's not a lot that i
would change and not a lot we have
changed in terms of characterizations or
story plots
um
but i know for me personally for keyleth
i was so excited
to see some of her big badass spell
casting moments realized because you do
these huge epic things that you know
are epic in your head when you're role
playing but to see
the epic animation team at titmouse
bring it into this full
anime glory oh man i can't wait for the
audience to see some of them it's
so good
yeah agreed i i think it's it's jumping
off of that of
when you describe something at the table
of
whatever you're doing in battle and
you're like oh god this looks so cool in
my head but i don't know if i'm fully
describing this correctly
that is that is the the difference for
me in jumping from the table to
animation because you get to fully see
that in a way that you know we wouldn't
be able to show at the table
and you're like oh yes
oh i look like a badass for like 10
seconds
you know it's it's it's and it's it's
the reason why you play in rpgs because
you want to like feel cool for a little
bit
and so seeing those moments for all of
us we're just
we just get so excited by it because
it's it's really special to watch that
and see that and know that
what you saw in your head is is coming
to life now
yeah there's such a piece of us in each
of these characters that you can't help
but watch keyleth or pike or grog do
something awesome and be like that's the
coolest i've ever been even though yes
but it's kind of me
man i'm cool
yeah that was cool
i will say changing up some npcs for the
story
if anything changed at all would be that
because when the story is truncated you
have the opportunity to take some you
know npcs that maybe weren't as
important in the stream and now we get
to flesh them out more and make them a
little more prominent in the animated
series we get to
adjust a few things with some of the
non-main characters to make them a
little more interesting and a little
more involved in the main story than
they might have been when we streamed it
originally so that was one cool thing we
got to kind of tweak and and alter a bit
awesome thank you so much guys and huge
congratulations i adore the show and i
watch it twice in a row oh my god thank
you so
much thank you